so we've got this so-called
investigation into Brett Kavanaugh and
we are quickly learning that while it is
extraordinarily likely that we're going
to get a conclusion to this
investigation and a vote on Brett
Kavanaugh possibly as soon as tomorrow
Friday we learned that the FBI was not
even allowed by the White House to talk
to the main players Brett Kavanaugh
himself
and dr. Christine Blasi Ford and you
might remember not to Pat myself on the
back because it was very obvious and
lots of people were saying it on Monday
I came to you and I said this so-called
investigation into accused sexual
assault or Brett Kavanaugh is going to
be a sham it is a sham the FBI was never
allowed to do a full investigation they
weren't allowed to examine the claims of
third accuser Julie sweat neck they were
limited in terms of who they could speak
to and Trump's defenders and Republicans
and Trump himself said now they can do
anything they want they can talk to
anybody they want to just make sure that
they wrap it up quickly but no one is
limiting what it is that they're allowed
to do Trump even tweeted about this I
showed you this tweet on Monday's show
and I'll show it to you again where
Donald Trump said quote NBC News
incorrectly reported as usual that I was
limiting the FBI investigation of judge
Kavanaugh and witnesses only to certain
people actually I want them to interview
whoever they deem appropriate at their
discretion please correct your reporting
we were skeptical that that was actually
the reality on the ground from day one
and now we we really know that for a
fact with every passing day we learn
more about the absurdity of this
investigation and it's ridiculous to
begin with to just have a week to do
this right if you have the potential
lifetime appointment of a man to the
highest court in the land for life I
don't know how many times I should
repeat that it's a lifetime appointment
how is it justified
have a week to investigate the potential
extraordinarily serious allegations
against him it's then even more
preposterous to say we're gonna vote
immediately when the investigation is
done the day after the investigation is
done we're going to vote because
senators need time to review the results
we also found out that it's not like
senators are all going to get a copy of
the results of the investigation there
is going to be one physical copy of the
investigation and senators all hundred
of them if they care to see it and maybe
not all of them do which is part of the
problem they are going to have to line
up and take turns to look at this one
physical copy of the investigation
according to a report from just hours
ago so the entire thing was ridiculous
in terms of its timeline to begin with
but now we've learned in the last 12 or
so hours that the investigation in terms
of its content is ridiculously hamstrung
by the White House to people with
knowledge of the details of the
investigation went to Bloomberg and
revealed that the FBI hasn't been
cleared by the White House to speak to
Brett Kavanaugh and dr. Ford themselves
as part of this so-called investigation
the investigation is effectively over by
the time you listen to this clip watch
this on youtube the investigation will
in all likelihood have concluded they
will not have spoken to Brett Kavanaugh
they will not have spoken to dr.
Christine Blasi Ford the White House has
said that the FBI instead of talking to
them instead of talking to Brett
Cavanaugh talking to dr. Ford they can
simply reread the transcript of the
testimony from last Thursday how
ridiculous is this so the the the
important question immediately becomes
what is the FBI doing about this one
would hope that when the FBI is told
okay you've got to investigate the
claims of dr. Christine Blasi Ford about
Brett Kavanaugh but you can't talk to
dr. Christine
Blasi Ford or Brett Kavanaugh one would
hope that the FBI would immediately say
it's not gonna fly that simply we can't
do an investigation in that way did they
do that not to our knowledge it appears
as though indeed the investigation is
going to be called complete without
actually speaking to two of the primary
people that are involved here
if the FBI can't speak to Cavanaugh and
Ford forget about all of the other
relevant witnesses if they can't at
least talk to those two how can anyone
say that this is a credible real
investigation and if you're asking
yourself why wouldn't the White House
want Cavanaugh to speak to the FBI the
immediate answer is well he might
incriminate himself but there's another
reason if the White House knows like
anybody who watched Cavanaugh's
testimony last week that Cavanaugh is a
huge liar you wouldn't want Cavanaugh
speaking to the FBI because we'd be
worried that he could end up like others
in Trump circle getting in trouble for
lying to the FBI lying to the FBI seems
to be something that is afflicting many
people in Donald Trump's circle and you
can be sure that lying to the FBI
wouldn't be a good thing for Cavanaugh
and realistically I've been speaking
about the similarities between Brett
Kavanaugh and Donald Trump if your
Trump's lawyer and you realize that
Trump lies all the time the last thing
you want is Trump sitting down with
Robert Muller's investigators you might
say rightly we'll hold on a second David
Cavanaugh already lied under oath to the
Senate he didn't get in trouble he's not
likely to get in trouble that's right
but it's much more likely that you get
into criminal trouble for lying directly
to FBI investigators than for lying
under oath to senators senators liked to
pretend that lying to them under oath is
simply not tolerated but how often do
you actually see charges brought against
someone for lying to the Senate
extraordinarily rarely lying to the
actual FBI investigators looking into
this maybe a bigger problem but
Republicans are gonna win this in in one
way or the other because from the
beginning you know I kind of have to
hand it to Republicans I don't know
whether Jeff Lakes
demand for the investigation was part of
the plot all along
or not but Mitch McConnell has
orchestrated this just perfectly
initially they say we don't want to
delay this we don't want an
investigation we've got to get that
ninth justice on the Supreme Court
Democrats want an investigation Jeff
Flake calls for an investigation you do
it and say listen Democrats aren't going
to be happy with this investigation why
are we even wasting our time you then
make sure that the investigation is
hamstrung and totally bogus
and then when Democrats say guys this
investigation was ridiculous Republicans
can say we said from the beginning that
Democrats weren't going to be satisfied
we've done everything we've been asked
and they're still not satisfied so it's
pathetic it's embarrassing it is toxic
and horrible but it is more than likely
going to work to get Brett Kavanaugh on
the Supreme Court and that's an absolute
atrocity that we're probably gonna have
to live with for the decades that
Cavanaugh will be on the court today's
program was made possible in part by
Blink accom / Packman i love bling cast
it's the really perfect app for anybody
who likes politics and learning and if
you're watching or listening to the
David Pakman show I'm sure you'll love
politics and learning and what blinka
studs is take the best and most popular
non-fiction books if they condense them
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting and you can
learn about politics philosophy
psychology economics often we don't have
the time to actually read as many books
as we would like I know that I'm at my
limit for how much I can read and this
way you can absorb the most important
valuable information from books in just
15 minutes maybe on your way to work
maybe on your way to the gym maybe
cooking vegan recipes at home whatever
is your thing and our audience can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it and I think you will
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for just about 5
bucks a month you can go to be li NK is
t-dot-com
/pa KMA n to sign up